Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. A long time ago, in a galaxy far, far away, it is a period of civil war. Rebel spaceships, striking from a hidden base, have won their first victory against the evil Galactic Empire. During the battle, rebel spies managed to steal secret plans to the Empire's ultimate weapon, the Death Star, a space station with enough power to destroy an entire planet. Pursued by the Empire's sinister agents, Princess Leia races home aboard her starship custodian of the stolen plans that can save her people and restore freedom to the galaxy so that dominic was dave prowse bodybuilder
感谢收听《历史的余味》（The Rest Is History）。想要获取每周的加更剧集、无广告收听体验、抢先收听系列节目以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请前往 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。很久很久以前，在一个遥远的银河系，正处于内战时期。义军飞船从一个秘密基地发起突袭，赢得了他们对抗邪恶银河帝国的首次胜利。在战斗中，义军间谍成功窃取了帝国终极武器“死星”的秘密计划，这是一座拥有足以摧毁整个行星力量的空间站。在帝国邪恶特工的追捕下，莱娅公主驾驶着她的星际飞船疾驰回家，她保管着那些能拯救她的人民并恢复银河系自由的被窃计划，所以多米尼克，那是戴夫·普劳斯，健美运动员。
what was he the green cross code man he was um and the actor who played darth vader in star wars and of course i was reading there the opening to Star Wars, that kind of scroll that appears. And I wanted to go with Dave Prowse because I actually met him. Oh, crikey. Well done, Tom. When I was 10, the year that Star Wars came out in Britain, he came in his Darth Vader robes to Salisbury Library. Wow.
他是那个“绿十字代码”先生吗？他是，嗯，也是在《星球大战》中饰演达斯·维达的演员。当然，我刚才读的是《星球大战》的开场，那种出现在屏幕上的滚动字幕。我想提到戴夫·普劳斯，因为我真的见过他。哦，天哪。干得好，汤姆。我10岁那年，《星球大战》在英国上映，他穿着达斯·维达的戏服来到了索尔兹伯里图书馆。哇。
And I was startled when I heard him speak. Yes. Because, of course, this is not the voice that he actually gets in the film, is it, Darth Vader? No, no. It's all kind of, oh, Luke, oh, all that kind of stuff. Is that James Earl Jones there, Tom? Yeah.
当我听到他说话时，我感到很惊讶。是的。因为当然，这不是他在电影中实际听到的声音，对吧，达斯·维达？不，不。那全是那种，哦，卢克，哦，诸如此类的东西。那是詹姆斯·厄尔·琼斯的声音吗，汤姆？是的。
Making his guest appearance. Yeah. All that kind of thing. Oh, wonderful. But very much part of my childhood memories, Star Wars. Yeah. And we are going to look at it, but with a kind of very distinctive angle, a historically themed angle today. Yes, because this episode is really, well, I mean, you wanted to call it Romans in Space.
客串出演。是的。诸如此类的事情。哦，太棒了。但《星球大战》确实是我童年记忆中非常重要的一部分。是的。我们今天要看看它，但会带有一个非常独特的视角，一个以历史为主题的视角。是的，因为这一集真的，我是说，你想把它叫做“太空中的罗马人”。
I did. Yes, which is a great title, actually, Tom. It's a very good title. So did you see Star Wars when it first came out? Yeah, I did. About 400 times. Did you? You thought it thought it was good yeah i thought it was great i remember laughing at the grand moff tarkin right right well we'll come back to uh to governor tarkin in about 15 minutes or so yeah i was totally obsessed with star wars as a boy so you know
我是这么想的。是的，这其实是个很棒的标题，汤姆。这是一个非常好的标题。那么你第一次看《星球大战》时看了吗？是的，我看了。看了大约400遍。真的吗？你觉得它很好？是的，我觉得它太棒了。我记得当时嘲笑大莫夫·塔金。对，对，好吧，我们大约15分钟后再回来谈谈塔金总督。是的，我小时候完全沉迷于《星球大战》，所以你知道。
child of the early 70s there must have been a point in my life where I thought about Star Wars every single day for hours, you know, about three year period where I just thought about Han and Luke and whatnot. And I had all the toys. Rather in the way that American men think about the Roman empire, you know, and perhaps there's a kind of link there. There may be a link there. But Dominic, as a historian of modern America, before we get on to the Romans, can you just situate Star Wars in the 1970s and kind of give a sense of its historical significance
作为70年代初出生的孩子，我生命中肯定有一段时间，我每天都要花几个小时思考《星球大战》，你知道，大约有三年时间，我满脑子都是汉、卢克之类的角色。我拥有所有的玩具。就像美国男人思考罗马帝国那样，你知道，也许这之间有一种联系。可能确实有联系。但是多米尼克，作为现代美国历史学家，在我们谈论罗马人之前，你能先将《星球大战》置于70年代的背景下，并谈谈它的历史意义吗？
as a cultural artifact? Oh, very good, Tom. We love a cultural artifact. So Star Wars is a product of the 1970s. Now, at this great distance, you can see how it completely and utterly reflects the era of Vietnam and Watergate and the sort of disillusionment that had set in with the Nixon presidency and
作为一个文化产物？哦，非常好，汤姆。我们喜欢文化产物。《星球大战》是70年代的产物。现在，从这么远的距离来看，你可以看出它如何完全且彻底地反映了越南战争和水门事件的时代，以及尼克松总统任期内所产生的幻灭感。
after. So its progenitor, George Lucas, is your sort of classic sort of baby boom, suburban, slightly disaffected, slightly idealistic kind of nerd, a bit like Steven Spielberg. So he was born in a place called Modesto, California, which is basically, it's not that far from San Francisco in Northern California. It's just a nondescript sort of middle-class American suburban town. Lucas is a very sort of nerdy young man. He goes to University of Southern California and he studies film. And he's part of this generation that come into cinema
之后。所以它的创造者乔治·卢卡斯，是你那种典型的婴儿潮一代、郊区出身、略带不满、略带理想主义的书呆子，有点像史蒂文·斯皮尔伯格。他出生在一个叫加利福尼亚州莫德斯托的地方，基本上，离北加州的旧金山并不远。那只是一个平淡无奇的中产阶级美国郊区小镇。卢卡斯是一个非常书呆子气的年轻人。他去了南加州大学学习电影。他是这一代进入电影界的人。
in the late 60s, early 70s, like his friend Francis Ford Coppola, who he was very close friends with, who made The Godfather. Lucas is slightly different because he's always very, he's always quite a nostalgic filmmaker. So his big breakthrough is a film called American Graffiti, which is kind of looking back to the 1950s. And he came up with the idea for Star Wars in the early 1970s, at the point at which
在60年代末、70年代初，就像他的朋友弗朗西斯·福特·科波拉，他们关系非常亲密，科波拉执导了《教父》。卢卡斯略有不同，因为他一直是一个相当怀旧的电影制作人。所以他的重大突破是一部名为《美国风情画》的电影，它有点回顾50年代。他在70年代初想出了《星球大战》的点子，当时。
the Nixon presidency was imploding. Because I gather, having read a bit around this, that the evil Emperor Palpatine, who again we may mention later in the show, was based on Nixon, according to Lucas. Is that true or not? I don't know how true that is, Tom. I think it's one of those things. Lucas has given about six billion interviews. He just makes up different things.
尼克松总统的任期正在崩溃。因为我收集到，在读了一些相关资料后，邪恶的帕尔帕廷皇帝——我们稍后可能会在节目中提到——是根据尼克松塑造的，据卢卡斯所说。这是真的吗？我不知道这有多真实，汤姆。我认为这是那种事情之一。卢卡斯接受过大约60亿次采访。他只是编造了不同的东西。
And he sort of says, well, there was a bit of Nixon in him and people say, oh, in that case, the emperor is definitely Nixon. But I think obviously, you know, the idea of an evil authority figure for people of Lucas's generation and his kind of cultural sensibility, Nixon was the great villain of the early 70s. And the other
他会说，嗯，他身上有一点尼克松的影子，人们就会说，哦，那样的话，皇帝肯定是尼克松。但我认为很明显，你知道，对于卢卡斯那一代人和他的文化敏感度来说，邪恶权威人物的概念，尼克松是70年代初的大反派。而另一件事。
thing that he's always said about it is that he was inspired by Joseph Campbell. Yeah. He was a great writer on mythology and the idea of universal hero. Yes. And that became, I mean, I remember first reading about that when I was a student, I thought, gosh, how unbelievably fascinating. Star Wars is so much deeper and more sophisticated than I ever imagined.
他一直说的是，他受到了约瑟夫·坎贝尔的启发。是的。他是一位伟大的神话学作家，提出了“英雄之旅”的概念。是的。这变成了，我是说，我记得我还是学生时第一次读到这个，我想，天哪，太令人着迷了。原来《星球大战》比我想象的要深刻和复杂得多。
And actually, I think now people think this is probably not quite true. Window dressing. This is window dressing. Lucas was looking back in, I don't know, the 1980s or 1990s or something and made an offhand remark and then people ran with it and turned it into this sort of great,
实际上，我现在认为人们觉得这可能不太真实。这只是装饰门面。这是装饰门面。卢卡斯是在80年代或90年代回顾时，随口说了一句，然后人们就顺着这个思路，把它变成了这种伟大的。
this great enterprise teasing out all the links between Star Wars and kind of, you know, ancient Indian mythology or something. Right, but we are going to do something similar with the Romans, aren't we? But just before we come on to that, for people who haven't seen Star Wars, and there are definitely people who haven't. Yes.
这种伟大的事业，挖掘《星球大战》与某种，你知道，古印度神话之类的联系。对，但我们也要对罗马人做类似的事情，不是吗？但在我们谈到那个之前，对于那些没看过《星球大战》的人来说，确实有人没看过。是的。
I mean, my daughters have never watched it. Oh, crikey. Well, I tried to make them watch it and they got so bored that they drifted off. That's poor. That's very poor, Tom. So I think it is a kind of period piece, although they've done multiple reworkings of it, haven't they, over the years? Yeah.
我是说，我的女儿们从来没看过。哦，天哪。好吧，我试着让她们看，但她们觉得太无聊了，就走开了。那太糟糕了。那真的很糟糕，汤姆。所以我认为它是一种时代作品，尽管多年来他们对它进行了多次重制，不是吗？是的。
The salient thing in the opening that I read so beautifully is that it's set in space. Yeah. It's science fiction, but it happens a long time ago. So can you just give us the very basic plot very, very quickly, the setting, for people who haven't seen it? Yeah. So essentially what George Lucas had wanted to do was to remake Flash Gordon. So Flash Gordon was this story about a guy who's catapulted into space. Flash, ah.
我在开场中读到的最显著的一点是，它发生在太空中。是的。它是科幻小说，但它发生在很久以前。所以你能为那些没看过的人快速简单地介绍一下基本情节和背景吗？是的。基本上，乔治·卢卡斯想做的是重拍《飞侠哥顿》。所以《飞侠哥顿》是一个关于一个人被弹射到太空的故事。飞侠，啊。
I should never have. Saviour of the universe. I really bitterly now regret bringing up Flash Gordon. You walked into that one. Yeah, I did. So Flash Gordon, very popular in the 1930s, a comic and then a kind of film serial. Lucas wanted to get the rights to do this,
我真不该。宇宙的救世主。我现在非常后悔提到了《飞侠哥顿》。你自投罗网了。是的，我确实。所以《飞侠哥顿》，在30年代非常流行，先是漫画，然后是电影系列。卢卡斯想获得版权来做这个。
this family-friendly story about a guy who's catapulted into space and he has all of these amazing adventures fighting an evil empire. He couldn't do that, so he writes basically his own version of Flash Gordon. But what distinguishes Star Wars from sort of pulp science fiction generally is that the very first film, he incorporates his kind of film school training. So there's lots of references to John Ford's film The Searchers or Kurosawa's
这个适合家庭观看的故事，关于一个人被弹射到太空，经历了一系列惊人的冒险，对抗一个邪恶帝国。他没能做到，所以他基本上写了他自己版本的《飞侠哥顿》。但《星球大战》与一般通俗科幻小说的区别在于，在第一部电影中，他融入了他电影学院的训练。所以有很多对约翰·福特电影《搜索者》或黑泽明的参考。
japanese films like the hidden fortress and the plot is princess leia who we heard about and think she's got these plans yes they get attacked she gets captured by darth vader who's an evil bloke wearing black robes right something happens that oh two robots yeah they crash on a planet r2 and 3po they get found by uh luke Skywalker, who is the kind of King Arthur figure. Yes, he is Arthur. And the sword from the stone is the lightsaber that is given by this old wizard. I say wizard, because he's referred to as a wizard at one point. Obi-Wan Kenobi.
日本电影，比如《战国英豪》，情节是莱娅公主，我们刚才听到的，她认为她有这些计划。是的，他们遭到袭击，她被达斯·维达俘虏，一个穿着黑袍的邪恶家伙。对，发生了一些事，哦，两个机器人，是的，他们坠毁在一个星球上，R2和3PO，他们被卢克·天行者发现，他就是那种亚瑟王式的人物。是的，他就是亚瑟。石中剑就是老巫师给他的光剑。我说巫师，因为他有一次被称为巫师。欧比旺·克诺比。
Obi-Wan Kenobi. Who is kind of the Merlin of the whole proceeding. Yes, the Merlin of the whole Enterprise. They go on this expedition to try and rescue the princess. Theo, quite rightly, is saying Ben Kenobi because he's really mainly called Ben rather than Obi-Wan in the very first film. The first film is actually a bit of an outlier. There are lots of things that we think of as being sort of typical of Star Wars that aren't in the first film or the first film deviates
欧比旺·克诺比。他有点像是整个过程中的梅林。是的，整个事业的梅林。他们去探险试图营救公主。西奥说得对，叫本·克诺比，因为在第一部电影中，他主要被称为本，而不是欧比旺。第一部电影实际上有点例外。我们认为《星球大战》典型的很多东西，在第一部电影中并不存在，或者第一部电影偏离了它们。
from them. Anyway, we don't need to go into that. Anyway, basically, the MacGuffin is that they have these plans. Yes. And they have to use them to blow up the Death Star that otherwise will kill everyone. Yes. This terrifying space station. He meets rogues and he has this little team of friends who go on the expedition. There's a slight Lord of the Rings element to it, the idea of going on the expedition. And surprise, surprise, it all ends happily. And they get medals at the end, except for Chewbacca who is denied a medal Tom
无论如何，我们不需要深入探讨那个。总之，基本上，麦格芬就是他们有这些计划。是的。他们必须用它们来炸毁死星，否则它会杀死所有人。是的。这个可怕的空间站。他遇到了流氓，他有一小群朋友去探险。这有一点《指环王》的元素，去探险的想法。惊喜，惊喜，结局很圆满。最后他们获得了奖章，除了丘巴卡，他被拒绝颁发奖章，汤姆。
in the triumph of the will reenactment scene yes because basically rather oddly it all goes very Nazi at the end doesn't it well it does a bit
在那个模仿《意志的胜利》的场景中。是的，因为基本上，很奇怪，最后一切都变得非常纳粹，不是吗？嗯，确实有一点。
yes so we wanted to focus particularly on Rome because this is the thing that is often the historical period that is often seen as inspiring
是的，所以我们想特别关注罗马，因为这通常被视为启发了《星球大战》的历史时期。
Star Wars just to pick up again on that Leni Riefenstahl thing so we talked about her in the series that we just finished about the Nazis we did that her portrayal as inspiring Star Wars. Just to pick up again on that Leni Riefenstahl thing. So we talked about her in the series that we just finished about the Nazis. We did. That her portrayal of Hitler at the Nuremberg rallies inspires the ending of Star Wars, where there's this kind of mass rally.
再次回到莱妮·里芬斯塔尔的话题，我们在刚结束的关于纳粹的系列节目中谈到了她。我们确实谈到了她对《星球大战》的启发。再次回到莱妮·里芬斯塔尔的话题。我们在刚结束的关于纳粹的系列节目中谈到了她。我们确实谈到了。她对纽伦堡集会上希特勒的描绘启发了《星球大战》的结局，那里有那种群众集会。
Yeah. There is a kind of Nazi interface, isn't there, between George Lucas making this film and the Romans, that the Romans kind of are standing in for the Nazis in quite a lot of the way that the Romans are seen. Absolutely. So the Nazis, we did our series about the Nazis and power. We were talking about Nazi iconography and Nazi propaganda. The Nazis were often looking back to Rome, weren't they? Yeah.
是的。在乔治·卢卡斯制作这部电影和罗马人之间，确实有一种纳粹的接口，不是吗？罗马人在很多方面被视为纳粹的替身。绝对是。所以纳粹，我们做了关于纳粹和权力的系列节目。我们谈到了纳粹的肖像学和纳粹宣传。纳粹经常回顾罗马，不是吗？是的。
I mean, the Eagle standards, the very idea of those sort of Nazi rallies, the idea of kind of the mass ranks of stormtroopers, the SA, or members of the Wehrmacht in their sort of shining helmets. And their eagles and their standards. And their eagles and their standards. I mean, the whole thing is very clearly aping what in the early 20th century people thought was kind of
我是说，鹰旗，那些纳粹集会的想法，那种成群结队的冲锋队、党卫军，或者穿着闪亮头盔的国防军成员。还有他们的鹰和旗帜。还有他们的鹰和旗帜。我是说，整件事非常明显地模仿了20世纪初人们认为的那种。
standard Roman imperial iconography. Don't you think, Tom? And so Darth Vader and the Empire command stormtroopers, which is obviously an allusion back to the Nazis. Are they legions as well? Is that something that is being played with, do you think? Or is this, again, kind of academics perhaps overthinking it?
标准的罗马帝国肖像学。你不觉得吗，汤姆？所以达斯·维达和帝国指挥着冲锋队，这显然是对纳粹的影射。他们也是军团吗？你认为这是在玩弄这个概念吗？还是说，这又是学者们想多了？
That might be academics overthinking it. I don't think the word legions is ever used, certainly not, I'm aware of, in the first three films in the original trilogy. Let's concentrate on that first film, the original film, which came out in the US in 77 and in Britain in 78. there are sort of clues as it were there are roman hints so you had a mention of the empire in the in the opening crawl that you read tom so beautifully um the only character who's mentioned in that opening text is princess leia and she's the first one apart from
那可能是学者们想多了。我不认为“军团”这个词被使用过，至少在我所知的最初三部曲中没有。让我们专注于第一部电影，那部1977年在美国、1978年在英国上映的原版电影。有一些线索，有一些罗马的暗示。你在我读的开场滚动字幕中提到了帝国，汤姆。那个开场文字中提到的唯一角色是莱娅公主，她是除了达斯·维达之外，我们在电影中见到的第一个主要角色。
darth vader of the principles that we meet in the film and she is quite classically dressed so she's the first one, apart from Darth Vader, of the principles that we meet in the film. And she is quite classically dressed. So she's wearing this sort of long flowing white robe, almost a little bit like a toga. Or, I mean, some classical scholars say she looks like a vestal virgin. I mean, also, she has this famous hairstyle, doesn't she? The kind of twin cinnamon buns on either side. Which, again, I remember reading may have been inspired by a 4th century BC statue found in Spain, the Lady of Elche, where she has identical hairstyle.
而且她穿得相当古典。所以她是除了达斯·维达之外，我们在电影中见到的第一个主要角色。而且她穿得相当古典。她穿着那种长长的、飘逸的白色长袍，几乎有点像托加长袍。或者，我是说，一些古典学者说她看起来像个维斯塔贞女。我是说，她还有那个著名的发型，不是吗？两边各有一个肉桂卷。这，我记得读过，可能受到了一尊在西班牙发现的公元前4世纪雕像“埃尔切夫人”的启发，她有着一模一样的发型。
Absolutely, and if people want to look that up, you look at the Lady of Elche, who's supposedly possibly Hellenistic or even Carthaginian, people think. She does have Princess Leia's hairstyle. Extraordinary. Anyway, so leia looks kind of classical when she's captured by darth vader and the stormtroopers she protests she
绝对是，如果人们想查一下，看看埃尔切夫人，人们认为她可能是希腊化时期甚至迦太基时期的。她确实有莱娅公主的发型。太不可思议了。总之，莱娅在被达斯·维达和冲锋队俘虏时看起来很古典，她抗议说。
says the imperial senate will not stand for this so we have this idea that there's a senate we're then introduced to luke skywalker who's the king arthur as you said he is a farm boy and basically his story is king arthur in the West. So he's on the Western frontier. He's a farm boy. It's very sort of the American prairie. But he similarly is wearing clothes that an extra would wear in a market scene in Cleopatra. Yes, or a biblical epic. Exactly.
她说“帝国参议院不会坐视不管的”，所以我们有了参议院的概念。然后我们被介绍了卢克·天行者，正如你所说，他是亚瑟王。他是个农场男孩，基本上他的故事就是西部的亚瑟王。他在西部边境。他是个农场男孩。这非常像美国大草原。但他同样穿着群众演员在《埃及艳后》市场场景中会穿的衣服。是的，或者史诗圣经电影。没错。
And he talks very excitedly about a rebellion against the empire, which is is very kind of i don't know jewish revolt or something he meets this character ben kenobi who is a kind of hermit stroke wizard he's a bit like a stylite from the sixth century tom you know he's a man of the desert a man of the desert he meets ben and it's actually ben who gives us a lot of the well what backstory there is so ben says to luke for over a thousand generations, the Jedi Knights were the guardians of peace and justice in the old Republic, before the dark times, before the Empire. So there he's sounding like a kind of a senator under Caligula or somebody. Right, exactly. So there you have established in those lines, the premise for the whole thing, that there has been this utopian republic and something has gone wrong.
他非常兴奋地谈论反抗帝国，这非常像，我不知道，犹太起义之类的。他遇到了这个角色本·克诺比，一个隐士兼巫师。他有点像6世纪的柱头修士，汤姆，你知道，他是沙漠中的人，沙漠中的人。他遇到了本，实际上是本给了我们很多背景故事。所以本对卢克说，一千多代以来，绝地武士一直是旧共和国和平与正义的守护者，在黑暗时代之前，在帝国之前。所以他听起来像卡里古拉统治下的参议员之类的。对，没错。所以你在那些台词中确立了整个故事的前提，即曾经有一个乌托邦式的共和国，但出了问题。
Corruption has set in and it has been replaced by a repressive empire. And the one other bit of politics we have in the whole film is when this character, Governor Tarkin, who is played by... This is the Grand Moff Tarkin. Right, Grand Moff Tarkin. So Lucas had two good actors in Star Wars,
腐败已经渗入，并被一个压迫性的帝国所取代。我们在整部电影中得到的另一部分政治信息是当这个角色，塔金总督，由……这是大莫夫·塔金。对，大莫夫·塔金。所以卢卡斯在《星球大战》中有两个好演员。
both British, both kind of prestigious. So he had Alec Guinness, who was Ben Kenobi. His sort of opposite number, as it were, was Peter Cushing playing the guy who's running the Death Star, Governor Tarkin. Peter Cushing was the kind of star of Hammer House Horror. He was very clipped. Either playing vampires or killing vampires.
都是英国人，都很有名望。他有亚历克·吉尼斯，饰演本·克诺比。他的对手，正如所说，是彼得·库欣，饰演管理死星的家伙，塔金总督。彼得·库欣是汉默恐怖电影公司的明星。他说话非常干脆。要么演吸血鬼，要么杀吸血鬼。
Yes, he was Van Helsing, he was Sherlock Holmes. He was the actor you would go to if you were doing a film about one of those characters or he'd be Dracula. And Governor Tarkin goes into a meeting of basically Nazi officers on the Death Star.
是的，他是范海辛，他是夏洛克·福尔摩斯。如果你要拍一部关于这些角色的电影，他就是你会找的演员，或者他会演德古拉。塔金总督走进死星上基本上是纳粹军官的会议。
They're clearly dressed as, you know, Hitler's high command circa 1942. And Governor Tarkin says to them, I've just had news. The Imperial Senate will no longer be of any concern to us. I've just received word the Emperor has dissolved the Council permanently.
他们显然穿着，你知道，1942年左右希特勒最高统帅部的制服。塔金总督对他们说，我刚得到消息。帝国参议院将不再与我们有关。我刚收到消息，皇帝已经永久解散了议会。
The last remnants of the old Republic have been swept away. The regional governors now have direct control over the territories. Fear will keep the local systems in line. Fear of this battle station. Right, so that could be kind of obviously drawing on the ocean of Hitler abolishing the Weimar Republic. I mean, that would be an obvious illusion. But the clearer illusion is to the collapse of the Roman Republic and the identification of the Roman Republic with political liberty and the replacement by Augustus and his heirs of the Republican system with an autocratic imperial system absolutely in the sense that the senate rich layer was somehow connected with that she and the other senators have been part of what appears to have been a kind of patrician talking shop and our senses this has somehow been allowed
旧共和国的最后残余已被扫除。地区总督现在直接控制领土。恐惧将使当地系统保持一致。对这个战斗站的恐惧。对，所以这显然是在借鉴希特勒废除魏玛共和国的例子。我是说，那将是一个明显的影射。但更清晰的影射是罗马共和国的崩溃，以及罗马共和国与政治自由的认同，以及奥古斯都及其继承人用专制帝国制度取代共和制度。绝对是，因为参议院与此有关，她和其他参议员似乎一直是某种贵族清谈馆的一部分，我们的感觉是这不知何故被允许。
to continue and it's withered and now the emperor has done away with it altogether that is all we get actually in that first i have to say when i watched it, I was obsessed by the Romans. I was in my kind of peak childhood Roman obsession. But I didn't really pick up any of that when I watched Star Wars. So I've read lots about how Star Wars is Roman. But in that film, it seems pretty buried, I have to say. Well, the funny thing about it is, so Star Wars now has this huge mythology that enthusiasts and indeed lucasfilm have created i mean the number of books star wars spin-off books and tv series and whatnot
继续存在，但它已经枯萎了，现在皇帝已经完全废除了它。实际上，在第一部电影中我们得到的就这些。我必须说，当我看它时，我沉迷于罗马人。我正处于童年时期对罗马的痴迷巅峰。但我看《星球大战》时并没有真正领会到这些。所以我读了很多关于《星球大战》如何具有罗马色彩的文章。但在那部电影中，我必须说，它似乎被埋得很深。嗯，有趣的是，所以《星球大战》现在拥有巨大的神话体系，爱好者们，实际上卢卡斯影业也创造了它。我是说，书籍、《星球大战》衍生书、电视剧之类的数量。
and comics is is vast but in the first film i think one of the reasons the first film is successful is that a little bit like tolkien its credibility lies in the fact that it hints at this deeper history yeah but it doesn't show it. So actually, it's very exciting for a 10-year-old to think, gosh, there was an old republic and there was all this stuff. But they never show it because that would probably be a bit disappointing, as indeed it was to prove. But a contrast with Tolkien, this isn't to diss Lucas, but Tolkien was a great scholar who knew vast, vast amounts about antiquity and was very, very skilled at drawing in and weaving together really quite learned and academic references to ancient history. George Lucas is not doing that, is he? I mean, he's not. He's interested in film.
和漫画是巨大的。但在第一部电影中，我认为第一部电影成功的原因之一是，它有点像托尔金，它的可信度在于它暗示了这种更深层的历史。是的，但它没有展示出来。所以实际上，对于一个10岁的孩子来说，想到“天哪，曾经有一个旧共和国，有所有这些东西”是非常令人兴奋的。但他们从不展示它，因为那可能会有点令人失望，正如后来证明的那样。但与托尔金相比，这不是为了贬低卢卡斯，但托尔金是一位伟大的学者，对古代史有着极其渊博的知识，并且非常擅长将真正博学和学术性的古代史参考资料编织在一起。乔治·卢卡斯没有这样做，不是吗？我是说，他没有。他对电影感兴趣。
He's not interested in, I don't know, Roman literature. His knowledge of Rome is that which you would expect. A well-educated, intelligent, intelligent you know a graduate of the University of Southern California who studied film yeah he's not he's not sitting up at night reading Salust you know I mean I don't think we should hold him to unfair standards one interesting thing about Star Wars is that right from the beginning it generates this huge industry so one of the things I mean one of the things that comes out almost straight away as a novelization and actually there's much more in the novelization i had the novelization as a boy and i
他对，我不知道，罗马文学不感兴趣。他对罗马的了解是你所期望的。一个受过良好教育、聪明的，你知道，南加州大学学习电影的毕业生。是的，他不是，他不是晚上坐着读萨卢斯特。你知道，我的意思是，我不认为我们应该用不公平的标准来要求他。《星球大战》有趣的一点是，从一开始它就产生了一个巨大的产业。所以其中一件事，我是说，几乎立刻出现的一件事是小说化，实际上小说化里有更多内容。我小时候有那本小说化，我。
loved it one of the things i actually loved was this so it was ghost written for george lucas by a sort of pulp science fiction writer called alan dean foster and there was a long description right at the beginning of how the old republic gave way to the empire the old republic was the republic of legend under the wise rule of the senate and the protection of the jedi knights but as so often happens when wealth and power pass beyond the admirable and attain the awesome there appear those evil ones who have greed to match so it was with the republic at its height like the greatest of trees able to withstand any external attack the republic rotted from, though the danger was not visible from outside.
很喜欢它。我实际上喜欢的一件事是这个：它是为乔治·卢卡斯代笔的，由一个叫艾伦·迪恩·福斯特的通俗科幻作家写的。在开头有一段很长的描述，关于旧共和国是如何让位于帝国的。旧共和国是传说中的共和国，在参议院的明智统治和绝地武士的保护下。但正如经常发生的那样，当财富和权力超越了令人钦佩的程度并达到令人敬畏的程度时，那些贪婪的邪恶之徒就会出现。共和国在鼎盛时期也是如此，就像最伟大的树木一样，能够抵御任何外部攻击，但共和国从内部腐烂了，尽管这种危险从外部看不出来。
And then this is actually this. It's in the book, not the film. We are told how restless, power-hungry individuals within the government, aided by the massive organs of commerce, propelled the campaign of the ambitious Senator Palpatine, who promised to reunite the disaffected among the people and to restore the remembered glory of the Republic. And so he surrounds himself, as it says, by bootlickers. So this is Julius Caesar, Palpatine is Julius Caesar, basically. Well, is he Julius Caesar or is he Augustus, Tom? Well, he's then Augustus when he proclaims himself emperor, right? It's a kind of a blurring of very, very negative portrayals of Caesar and of Augustus.
然后这实际上是这个。它在书里，不在电影里。我们被告知政府内部那些焦躁不安、渴望权力的人，在商业机构的帮助下，推动了雄心勃勃的帕尔帕廷参议员的竞选，他承诺重新团结人民中不满的人，并恢复共和国被铭记的荣耀。于是他像书中所说的那样，被马屁精包围。所以这就是尤利乌斯·凯撒，帕尔帕廷基本上就是尤利乌斯·凯撒。嗯，他是尤利乌斯·凯撒还是奥古斯都，汤姆？嗯，当他宣布自己为皇帝时，他就是奥古斯都，对吧？这是一种对凯撒和奥古斯都非常非常负面描绘的模糊。
Exactly. And I think what's fascinating about this, what I find interesting about this is all of that stuff, I'm sure Alan Dean Foster and George Lucas didn't think very much about it. I'm sure this wasn't conscious. But that idea that the whole enterprise was destroyed from within, it couldn't be destroyed from without, it was destroyed from within.
没错。我认为这令人着迷的地方，我发现有趣的地方是所有这些东西，我相信艾伦·迪恩·福斯特和乔治·卢卡斯并没有过多考虑。我相信这不是有意的。但那种整个事业从内部被摧毁的想法，它不能从外部被摧毁，它是从内部被摧毁的。
And it was destroyed by people hungry for power, by bootlickers and the organs of commerce and all of this sort of thing. I think that's quite Gabonian. Well, it's 18th century American specifically. Yes. Because America is founded with this idea that it's a republic. Benjamin Franklin famously says it will be a republic if you can keep it. And that anxiety that the republic might collapse and be replaced by an autocracy as Rome had been, and the American Republic is founded on the Roman Republic, I don't know the degree to which this is something that American students study in their history classes. But it's kind of in the air, the fact that the visuals of the American Republic
它被渴望权力的人、马屁精、商业机构和所有这些东西摧毁了。我认为这很有吉本风格。嗯，这是18世纪美国特有的。是的。因为美国建立时就带有它是共和国的想法。本杰明·富兰克林曾有名言说，如果你能保持它，它就是一个共和国。那种担心共和国可能会崩溃并被专制取代，就像罗马那样，而美国共和国是建立在罗马共和国基础上的。我不知道美国学生在历史课上学习这个的程度。但这在空气中，美国共和国的视觉效果。
are so Roman means that that has always been an anxiety. Well, that anxiety, that fear of ambition, corruption, I mean, the mention of commerce and wealth, the idea of fear of luxury. Those are very 18th century ideas, aren't they? And they were very popular on both sides of the Atlantic in the political classes. And so Gibbon, when he wrote The Decline and Fall of the Roman Empire, he moved in circles where people were dissing luxury and dissing ambition and corruption all the time. Yes. And that sort of idea that great empires or great republics are undermined by the decadence and the degeneracy of their ruling classes, and then a strong man will arise to take power. I mean, we all have that to some degree, don't we?
如此罗马化，意味着这一直是一种焦虑。嗯，那种焦虑，对野心、腐败的恐惧，我是说，提到商业和财富，对奢侈的恐惧。那些是非常18世纪的想法，不是吗？它们在大西洋两岸的政治阶层中非常流行。所以吉本在写《罗马帝国衰亡史》时，他所处的圈子里人们一直在贬低奢侈、贬低野心和腐败。是的。那种伟大的帝国或伟大的共和国被其统治阶级的颓废和堕落所破坏，然后一个强人将崛起夺取权力的想法。我是说，我们都有某种程度上的这种想法，不是吗？
And we've absorbed it from popular culture. Yes, but here's my question on that. Yeah. You're talking about how these books are written to tie in with the success of Star Wars. And then in due course, George Lucas revisits the Star Wars universe and he comes up with three films that trace,
我们从流行文化中吸收了它。是的，但这是我的问题。是的。你谈到这些书是如何为了配合《星球大战》的成功而写的。然后适时地，乔治·卢卡斯重访了《星球大战》宇宙，他想出了三部电影来追踪。
we discover who Darth Vader is, his backstory. And the backdrop to this is the implosion of the Republic and its replacement by an empire. But presumably this was not in Lucas's mind when he first made Star Wars. Is this stuff that basically scholars and enthusiasts and geeks have been pouring over it and they have kind of drawn out these echoes? And is George Lucas then thinking, oh, wow, it's cleverer than I thought, or it has more echoes than I thought. And is he perhaps kind of responding to that? I think possibly to some extent, Tom. So Lucas said, after Star Wars became successful, he said, this is actually episode four. Now it
我们发现了达斯·维达是谁，他的背景故事。而背景是共和国的内爆及其被帝国取代。但据推测，卢卡斯在最初制作《星球大战》时并没有想到这一点。这些基本上是学者、爱好者和极客们一直在钻研的东西，他们从中引出了这些回声吗？乔治·卢卡斯当时是否在想，哦，哇，它比我想象的更聪明，或者它有比我想象的更多的回声。他是否在某种程度上回应了这一点？我想在某种程度上可能是这样，汤姆。所以卢卡斯在《星球大战》成功后说，这实际上是第四部。现在它。
wasn't initially branded as episode four. When you went to see Star Wars in 1977, it didn't say episode four. But when I went to see it, when it was re-released in 1980, when The Empire Strikes Back came out, they had put on the Episode 4 branding. Because I can remember saying to my dad at the cinema, we've made a terrible mistake. We've come late. This is the fourth episode and we've missed the first three.
最初并没有被标记为第四部。当你1977年去看《星球大战》时，它没有写第四部。但当我1980年去看它重映时，当《帝国反击战》上映时，他们加上了第四部的品牌。因为我记得我在电影院对我爸爸说，我们犯了一个严重的错误。我们来晚了。这是第四部，我们错过了前三部。
Whether he was really intending to make these prequels, I suspect probably not. He sort of would airily talk about it. But again, it added to the sense of a deep history. You know, actually, you're coming in the middle of the story and people loved that. But those first three episodes, which I saw the first one, I thought it was so dull. I mean, I'd really rather have watched a film about trade negotiations in Brussels. Well, you did. You mean The Phantom Menace? Yeah, it's basically what it is. The Phantom Menace is what we're talking about. So those three films, are the allusions to Rome clearer in those?
他是否真的打算拍这些前传，我怀疑可能没有。他会轻描淡写地谈论它。但同样，它增加了深厚历史感。你知道，实际上，你是从故事中间进来的，人们喜欢那样。但那前三部，我看了第一部，我觉得太无聊了。我是说，我宁愿看一部关于布鲁塞尔贸易谈判的电影。嗯，你看了。你是说《幽灵的威胁》？是的，基本上就是这样。《幽灵的威胁》就是我们正在谈论的。所以那三部电影，对罗马的影射更清晰吗？
Are they more overt? They're much more overt. So not necessarily in The Phantom Menace. I mean, these, by the way, for the avoidance of doubt, some of our listeners may like these films. I have to be honest and say, although I love Star Wars, I absolutely loathe these films. Anyway, that's by the by.
它们更明显吗？它们明显得多。所以不一定是在《幽灵的威胁》中。我是说，顺便说一句，为了避免怀疑，我们的一些听众可能喜欢这些电影。我必须诚实地说，虽然我喜欢《星球大战》，但我绝对讨厌这些电影。总之，那是题外话。
They are more overt. So the story, the theme is the emergence of this Elpropalpatine. I think what made it so disappointing for people of my age is that we had built up, we had our own private versions, you know, as people tend to do, like people did with the Fall of Numenor and the Lord of the Rings, Tom. We had our own vision of what this would have looked like. And then when you discover it's sort of computer generated Jar Jar Binks aliens and whatever, it's just so depressing. Anyway, the one thing that is quite interesting is the emergence of this guy Palpatine. He has secretly generated, Tom, all these sort of civil
它们更明显。所以故事，主题是这个帕尔帕廷皇帝的出现。我认为让我这一代人感到失望的是，我们已经建立了自己的私人版本，你知道，正如人们倾向于做的那样，就像人们对《指环王》中努门诺尔的陷落所做的那样，汤姆。我们有自己对这看起来会是什么样子的愿景。然后当你发现它是某种电脑生成的加加·宾克斯外星人等等时，真是太令人沮丧了。总之，有一点很有趣，就是这个帕尔帕廷家伙的出现。他秘密地制造了，汤姆，所有这些内战。
wars and separatist movements in order to be given emergency powers to deal with them. And so he's given these emergency powers in the film Attack of the Clones. I think Augustus is the better comparison than Julius Caesar. He is given by the Senate these powers, and he says to them, it is with great reluctance that I've agreed to this calling. I love democracy. I love the Republic. Once this crisis has abated, I will lay down the powers you have given me. Of course, that is a Roman idea that someone will be awarded the powers of a dictator and then will surrender them. And then in the final film of that prequel trilogy, Revenge of the Sith,
战争和分裂运动，以便被授予紧急权力来处理它们。所以他在电影《克隆人的进攻》中被授予了这些紧急权力。我认为奥古斯都比尤利乌斯·凯撒更适合比较。他被参议院授予了这些权力，他对他们说，我非常不情愿地同意了这个呼吁。我热爱民主。我热爱共和国。一旦这场危机平息，我将交出你们给我的权力。当然，这是一个罗马式的想法，即某人将被授予独裁者的权力，然后会交出它们。然后在前传三部曲的最后一部《西斯的复仇》中。
he orchestrates a series of prescriptions, like the prescriptions that claim the life of Cicero, the prescriptions of Antony and Octavian. And again, you think here, this is a deliberate echo, do you think? I don't know how deliberate it is. There's also something in Light of the Long Knives about it, I guess, a sort of internal purge. The massacre of the Jedi Knights.
他策划了一系列清洗，就像夺去西塞罗生命的清洗，安东尼和屋大维的清洗。同样，你在这里想，这是一个故意的回声吗？我不知道它有多故意。关于它还有一些“长刀之夜”的影子，我想，一种内部清洗。绝地武士的大屠杀。
And then there's this scene which is often sort of mocked on social media when he's surrounded by gibbering aliens and flying saucers. And he says, in order to ensure our security and continuing stability, the Republic will be reorganised into the first galactic empire for a safe and secure society." And Natalie Bortman's character, Queen Amidala, who is Luke and Leia's mother, she says very earnestly, so this is how liberty dies with thunderous applause. So she is the Cicero of the Star Wars world. Exactly. So again, this is Rome in the era of Augustus and Tiberius or whatever, that the Senate has basically, in its sort of supine way, is handing over power to a power-hungry, malevolent character who affects this modesty, as of course Augustus did, but in reality is more ruthless than anybody. Now, there's an Australian classical scholar called Michael Charles who wrote an article about this in the journal Classical World, Remembering and Restoring the Republic.
然后有这个场景，在社交媒体上经常被嘲笑，当他被叽叽喳喳的外星人和飞碟包围时。他说，“为了确保我们的安全和持续稳定，共和国将被重组为第一个银河帝国，以实现一个安全稳定的社会。”娜塔莉·波特曼的角色，阿米达拉女王，也就是卢克和莱娅的母亲，她非常严肃地说，“自由就是这样死去的，伴随着雷鸣般的掌声。”所以她是《星球大战》世界的西塞罗。没错。所以同样，这是奥古斯都和提比略时代的罗马，参议院基本上以其顺从的方式，正在将权力移交给一个渴望权力、心怀恶意的角色，他表现出这种谦逊，正如奥古斯都当然做的那样，但实际上比任何人都更无情。现在，有一位澳大利亚古典学者叫迈克尔·查尔斯，他在《古典世界》杂志上写了一篇关于这个的文章，《铭记与恢复共和国》。
And he says one of the funny things about this, he says, and again, this is completely unconscious, I think, is that in Rome, people who criticized, people who were ambivalent about the rise of Julius Caesar, most obviously, and then I suppose Augustus, they were the patrician elite, weren't they, Tom? What do you call them? The bonnie?
他说关于这个的一件有趣的事情是，他说，同样，我认为这是完全无意识的，在罗马，批评、对尤利乌斯·凯撒的崛起持矛盾态度的人，最明显的是，我想是奥古斯都，他们是贵族精英，不是吗，汤姆？你叫他们什么？邦尼？
Yeah, the optimates. The good guys. These are the people who look back, who are upholders of tradition, who identify themselves with all that is best in Roman tradition and who have to be incredibly rich. And the sense is in the Star Wars universe that all the defenders of the Republic are very, very posh and rich. I mean, they're literally princesses. They are. Right. Absolutely. And queens. Yes. So the person who says that line about liberty dying is Queen Amidala. Her daughter is Princess Leia. And Princess Leia is the person who carries the torch of kind of republicanism.
是的，贵族派。好人。这些人回顾过去，是传统的维护者，他们认同罗马传统中最好的一切，而且必须非常有钱。在《星球大战》宇宙中，所有共和国的捍卫者都非常非常时髦和富有。我是说，他们字面上是公主。他们是。对。绝对是。还有女王。是的。所以说那句关于自由死亡台词的人是阿米达拉女王。她的女儿是莱娅公主。而莱娅公主是那个扛着共和主义火炬的人。
Well, this will be familiar to people who may not have read books on Roman history, but have seen Gladiator, where in Gladiator you have the evil emperor, Commodus. Yes. And then you have Derek Jacoby playing the Senate, which is the guardian of Rome's ancient liberties. And I'm just wondering, this sense of the kind of the Roman character in Star Wars, it might not be coming from Gibbon, but it might be coming from those kind of roman epics absolutely because obviously gladiator is post star wars but you had all those epics ben-hur for the roman empire all that kind of thing and actually in those it's the british who are who are the baddies and the americans who
嗯，这对那些可能没读过罗马史书，但看过《角斗士》的人来说会很熟悉，在《角斗士》中你有邪恶的皇帝康茂德。是的。然后你有德里克·雅各比饰演参议院，它是罗马古老自由的守护者。我只是在想，《星球大战》中这种罗马角色的感觉，它可能不是来自吉本，但它可能来自那种罗马史诗。绝对是，因为显然《角斗士》是在《星球大战》之后，但你有所有那些史诗，《宾虚》关于罗马帝国，所有那种东西。实际上在那些电影中，英国人是坏人，美国人是。
are who are the freedom fighters and indeed the the Christians, because the Jedi could be, you know, there are kind of echoes of the way that early Christians play the role in Quo Vadis or Demetrius and the Gladiators, things like that. I think that's totally right, Tom. And in fact, there's a scholar who has written lots about this who agrees with you called Martin Winkler. That's tremendous to know. And he has pointed out that alec guinness who plays ben kenobi obi-wan kenobi he would have been well known to american audiences for a whole host of roles but one of them was playing marcus aurelius of course in the film the fall of the roman empire in 1964 yes of course the film that is the direct model for gladiator i mean gladiator is really a remake of the fall of the roman empire yeah and you know marcus aurelius this sort of stoical character philosophical um he dies in
是自由战士，确实还有基督徒，因为绝地武士可能是，你知道，有早期基督徒在《暴君焚城录》或《德米特里与角斗士》中扮演角色的回声。我认为那是完全正确的，汤姆。事实上，有一位写了很多关于这个的学者同意你的观点，叫马丁·温克勒。知道这一点太棒了。他指出，饰演本·克诺比、欧比旺·克诺比的亚历克·吉尼斯，他因扮演各种角色而为美国观众所熟知，但其中之一是在1964年的电影《罗马帝国沦亡录》中饰演马可·奥勒留。是的，当然，那部电影是《角斗士》的直接模型。我是说，《角斗士》实际上是《罗马帝国沦亡录》的重拍。是的，你知道，马可·奥勒留，这种斯多葛派的角色，哲学上的……他死于。
the course of the film i mean there are kind of parallels you can tease out with his ben kenobi character and actually both martin winkler and this guy i mentioned earlier what's his name michael charles they point out that star wars shares what they call a linguistic paradigm with those toga films of the 50s and 60s so spartacus quavardis ben-hur and so on so in star wars a character like han solo harrison ford's character the kind of rogue yeah the way he's cracking yeah he's like a character who's fallen out of a western or something yeah he speaks like somebody in sort of 1960s america so he says famously i mean his most famous line is i have a bad feeling about this now you contrast that with the character we mentioned earlier peter cushing's governor tarkin tarkman by the way tarkman the proud tom yeah of course
在电影的进程中，我的意思是，你可以梳理出他与本·肯诺比这个角色之间的某种相似之处。事实上，马丁·温克勒和我之前提到的那个家伙——他叫什么来着？迈克尔·查尔斯——他们都指出，《星球大战》与50和60年代的那些“托加电影”（古罗马题材电影）共享着他们所谓的语言范式，比如《斯巴达克斯》、《奎瓦迪斯》、《宾虚》等等。所以在《星球大战》中，像汉·索罗——哈里森·福特饰演的角色——那种流氓角色，是的，他说话的方式，他就像一个从西部片里走出来的角色，或者类似的东西。是的，他说话就像60年代美国的某个人，所以他有一句名言，他最著名的一句台词是：“我对此有种不祥的预感。”现在，你把它与我们之前提到的彼得·库欣饰演的塔金总督进行对比——顺便说一下，塔金，那个骄傲的汤姆，当然。
the last raymond king the incarnation of tyranny yeah and governor tarkin i mean one of the first things he says he's talking to princess leia unleashed the death ray all that kind of thing he says he never says unleash the death rate he says, he's talking to Princess Leia. Unleash the death ray. All that kind of thing. He says, he never says unleash the death ray. He says, charming to the last, you don't know how hard I found it, signing the order to terminate your life. So he speaks like a sort of American parody. Yeah. You know, it's like Mel Gibson's The Patriot or something.
最后一个雷蒙德王，暴政的化身。是的，塔金总督，我的意思是，他说的第一件事，他正在和莱娅公主说话，释放死亡射线，诸如此类的事情。他说，他从不说释放死亡射线。他说，他正在和莱娅公主说话。释放死亡射线。诸如此类的事情。他说，他从不说释放死亡射线。他说：“到最后依然迷人，你不知道我签下处决你的命令时有多么艰难。”所以他说话就像某种美国式的模仿。是的，你知道，就像梅尔·吉布森的《爱国者》之类的电影。
Yeah. And actually, this is directly copying what happened in all of those Roman epics. But also kind of Pontius Pilate. Yeah. Yeah. I guess so. It pains me to sentence you to death, Nazarene. So in all those Roman epics, the hero is American. So Charlton Heston, obviously in Ben-Hur,
是的。实际上，这直接抄袭了所有那些罗马史诗电影中的情节。但也有一点像本丢·彼拉多。是的，我想是这样。他说：“判你死刑让我很痛苦，拿撒勒人。”所以在所有那些罗马史诗中，英雄都是美国人。比如查尔顿·赫斯顿，显然是在《宾虚》里。
Kirk Douglas in Spartacus, and they have American accents and they speak in a mid-century way. But the villains are always British speaking in an old-fashioned clipped way. So Peter Ustinov's Nero, I mean, Laurence Olivier as Crassus in Spartacus. Yes.
柯克·道格拉斯在《斯巴达克斯》里，他们都有美国口音，说话方式也是中世纪风格的。但反派总是英国人，说着那种老派、短促的英语。比如彼得·乌斯蒂诺夫饰演的尼禄，还有劳伦斯·奥利弗在《斯巴达克斯》中饰演的克拉苏。是的。
And indeed, the two Commoduses are both played by North American actors affecting British accents. So Christopher Plummer, who sounds very British anyway, actually. Friend of the show. Yes, friend of the show from The Sound of Music. And Joaquin Phoenix inenix in gladiator and
事实上，两个康茂德都是由操着英国口音的北美演员扮演的。比如克里斯托弗·普卢默，他听起来本来就很像英国人。他是节目的朋友。是的，来自《音乐之声》的节目朋友。还有《角斗士》里的华金·菲尼克斯。
obviously what this reflects is the is this again probably unconsciously is the identification of britishness with kind of empire oppression with cruelty and oppression yeah and that's how we like it tom to be honest and people with american accents in these toga epics tend to be as you say christian martyrs jewish freedom, all of those kinds of things. And this presumably is why George Lucas wouldn't allow Dave Prowse to actually speak. Yes. Because it would give away the fact. Luke, I am your father.
显然，这反映出的——可能又是无意识的——是将英国身份与帝国压迫、残暴和压迫联系在一起。是的，老实说，汤姆，我们就是喜欢这样。而在这些托加史诗中，操着美国口音的人往往是，正如你所说，基督教殉道者、犹太自由斗士，诸如此类。这大概就是为什么乔治·卢卡斯不允许戴夫·普劳斯亲自配音的原因。是的。因为那会暴露这个事实。“卢克，我是你父亲。”
Yeah, I mean, it wouldn't work, would it? Now, the funny thing about the Toga epics is that they themselves, of course, are products of a particular political moment because they're Cold War stories. Yeah. that they themselves of course are products of a particular political moment because they're Cold War stories so lots of film scholars have said you know these films project I mean what they're selling is a
是的，我的意思是，那行不通，对吧？现在，关于托加史诗有趣的一点是，它们本身当然是特定政治时刻的产物，因为它们是冷战故事。是的，它们本身当然是特定政治时刻的产物，因为它们是冷战故事。所以很多电影学者说，你知道，这些电影投射出的——我的意思是，它们兜售的是一种
conflict between on the one hand democracy and freedom and on the other totalitarianism so the Roman Empire stands in for the Soviet Empire
一方面是民主与自由，另一方面是极权主义之间的冲突。所以罗马帝国代表了苏联帝国。
although interestingly Spartacus was written by a guy called Dalton Trumbo who had been blacklisted. And there is an argument that actually the films are also about the anxieties of empire, you know, and the anxieties of power and all that. But I think what you could say then is that the idea that Star Wars is an allegory of Roman history isn't true. That would be to over-dignify it or perhaps to simplify it, because actually, this is emerging in a kind of mixing of all kinds of vaguely understood historical ideas.
尽管有趣的是，《斯巴达克斯》的编剧是一个叫道尔顿·特朗勃的人，他曾被列入黑名单。有一种观点认为，这些电影实际上也是关于帝国的焦虑，你知道，关于权力的焦虑等等。但我认为你可以说，《星球大战》是罗马历史寓言的说法并不属实。那会过度美化它，或者说简化它，因为实际上，这是一种各种模糊理解的历史观念的混合体。
I think that's absolutely right. So the villains in Star Wars are Nixon's Republicans, they are the Nazis, they are the Soviets, they are the British in the Revolutionary War, and they are the Romans. And perhaps the Romans lie as the furthest back. And that sense that Star Wars is set in the distant past, the ancient past, that kind of Roman quality does give it a patina of class that it might not otherwise have. And I think what that also depends upon, Tom, is the way in which the idea of Roman history
我认为这绝对正确。所以《星球大战》中的反派是尼克松的共和党人，他们是纳粹，他们是苏联人，他们是独立战争中的英国人，他们也是罗马人。也许罗马人处于最久远的过去。那种《星球大战》设定在遥远的过去、古代的感觉，那种罗马式的特质确实赋予了它一种原本可能没有的古典韵味。而且我认为这也取决于，汤姆，罗马历史的观念
is built into the American Republic from the very beginning. Wow. I mean, that's how they set it up, right? They didn't say, let's become a new American empire. They said there'd be a republic, the founding fathers. A senate. Yeah, a senate. The capital.
从一开始就融入了美利坚共和国之中。哇。我的意思是，他们就是这样建立它的，对吧？他们没有说，让我们成为一个新的美利坚帝国。他们说，将会有个共和国，国父们。一个参议院。是的，一个参议院。国会大厦。
George Washington being Cincinnatus. Yeah. And that fear, we've talked about this so many times and the rest is history. That fear, which is built into American-ness, that the republic could one day become an empire, that terror, that fate is at hand. And that's actually what animates George Lucas's moral political universe. Yes, it's the fear that the exemplar that shadows it is the end of the Roman Republic.
乔治·华盛顿就是辛辛纳图斯。是的。那种恐惧——我们已经谈过很多次了，剩下的就是历史了——那种融入美国精神的恐惧，即共和国有一天可能会变成帝国，那种恐怖，那种命运即将来临。而这正是驱动乔治·卢卡斯道德政治宇宙的核心。是的，这种恐惧在于，笼罩着它的榜样就是罗马共和国的终结。
But there is, of course, another decline and fall that can be adduced from Roman history, which is the collapse of the Roman Republic. But there is, of course, another decline and fall that can be adduced from Roman history, which is the collapse of the empire itself. And that also has been, I think, incredibly influential on science fiction, perhaps less so in film, more so in literature. And we know that George Lucas was influenced by perhaps the most celebrated of all these kind of fictional reworkings of the decline of all of the Roman Empire. And I think we should take a break now. And when we come back, Dominic, perhaps you'd allow me to have a look at that. I would love that, Tom. Thank you very much. Do you know what? I can't wait. I absolutely can't wait. See you after the break. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The
当然，从罗马历史中还可以推导出另一种衰亡，那就是罗马共和国的崩溃。但当然，从罗马历史中还可以推导出另一种衰亡，那就是帝国本身的崩溃。我认为这对科幻小说也产生了极其深远的影响，在电影中可能少一些，但在文学中则更多。我们知道乔治·卢卡斯受到了这些关于罗马帝国衰亡的虚构重构中最著名作品的影响。我想我们现在应该休息一下。当我们回来时，多米尼克，也许你能让我看看那个。我很乐意，汤姆。非常感谢。你知道吗？我等不及了。我绝对等不及了。休息后见。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《
Rest Is Entertainment it's your weekly fix of entertainment news reviews splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment
剩下的就是娱乐》，这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论、一点演艺圈八卦的固定节目，在我们的问答环节，我们将揭开娱乐界的幕布。
and we tell you how it all works we have just launched our members club if you want ad free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets head to therestisentertainment.com
我们告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部，如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集以及提前获得现场演出门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。
that's therestisentertainment.com. Galactic Empires reached the cinema with this group of films, which here and there offered more than a whiff of the foundation. No, I don't mind. Imitation is the sincerest form of flattery, and I certainly imitated Edward Gibbon, so I can scarcely object if someone imitates me that was the very well spoken isaac asimov who knew he came from the
那是 therestisentertainment.com。银河帝国随着这批电影进入了电影院，它们不时地散发出《基地》的气息。不，我不介意。模仿是最真诚的奉承，我当然模仿了爱德华·吉本，所以如果有人模仿我，我几乎无法反对。那是口才极好的艾萨克·阿西莫夫，他知道他来自
cotswolds that was isaac asimov tom uh and he was talking about star wars so isaac asimov there says he's detected more than a whiff of the foundation in George Lucas's Star Wars saga. So Isaac Asimov is one of those names that if you're not very familiar with science fiction, you've probably heard the name, but you don't know who he is. So Tom, who is Isaac Asimov? So Asimov actually didn't come from the Cotswolds. He came from Russia and his family emigrated to America in 1923. I think he was about three.
科茨沃尔德。那是艾萨克·阿西莫夫，汤姆。他在谈论《星球大战》。所以艾萨克·阿西莫夫在那里说，他在乔治·卢卡斯的《星球大战》传奇中察觉到了不止一丝《基地》的气息。所以艾萨克·阿西莫夫是那种如果你不太熟悉科幻小说，你可能听过他的名字，但不知道他是谁的名字之一。所以汤姆，艾萨克·阿西莫夫是谁？所以阿西莫夫实际上并不是来自科茨沃尔德。他来自俄罗斯，他的家人在1923年移民到美国。我想他当时大约三岁。
He was intellectually brilliant, brilliant scientist, but also fascinated by history and literature. And he became probably the most celebrated science fiction writer of the 20th century, I would guess. So he's probably famous for three things. The first is his enormous mutton chops. He had absolutely huge sideburns. Secondly, and there's been quite a lot of talk about this recently because of AI, he came up with the three laws of robotics, which is kind of basically designed to stop robots from killing you. Right, yes.
他才华横溢，是一位杰出的科学家，但也对历史和文学着迷。我想他可能成为了20世纪最著名的科幻小说作家。所以他可能因三件事而出名。第一是他巨大的羊排胡。他有非常大的鬓角。其次，最近因为人工智能，关于这一点有很多讨论，他提出了机器人三定律，这基本上是为了防止机器人杀死你。对，是的。
So there's quite a lot of discussion about should these actually be enshrined. And the third is he wrote this kind of massively, massively influential series of novels called Foundation. And there's a TV series, I think, on Apple at the moment, which came out in the early 50s. Three novels, Foundation, Foundation and Empire, Second Foundation. And this was directly inspired by Gibbon. I mean, there's no question about that. Asimov directly modelled it on it.
所以有很多关于这些是否应该被奉为圭臬的讨论。第三是他写了一系列影响极其深远的系列小说，名为《基地》。目前苹果公司好像有一部电视剧，它是在50年代初出版的。三部曲：《基地》、《基地与帝国》、《第二基地》。这直接受到了吉本的启发。我的意思是，毫无疑问。阿西莫夫直接以它为蓝本。
So it opens with someone arriving in the planet of Trantor. And so the opening, there were nearly 25 million inhabited planets in the galaxy then, and not one but owed allegiance to the empire whose seat was on Trantor. It was the last half century in which that could be said. So this is the equivalent of someone arriving in Rome in 400. Or is it a sort of a veiled reference to that bit in Gibbon when Gibbon says, you know, if you had to pick an age, you would have picked the age of the Antonines or whatever it is. But that's several centuries before, isn't it? I mean, the decline is about to happen. Okay. Right. You know, it's directly about to happen. And the parabola of Asimov's narrative directly follows that of Gibbon. So you have scenes in which imperial plenipotentiaries visit outposts of the Empire for the very last time. You get kind of interstellar equivalents of the barbarian kingdoms. All right, yeah.
所以它以某人到达川陀星球开篇。开篇写道，当时银河系有近2500万个有人居住的行星，每一个都向总部位于川陀的帝国效忠。这是能说出这句话的最后半个世纪。所以这相当于某人在400年到达罗马。或者这是一种对吉本那段话的隐晦引用，吉本说，你知道，如果你必须选择一个时代，你会选择安敦尼时代之类的。但那是几个世纪前，不是吗？我的意思是，衰落即将发生。好的。对。你知道，这直接关于即将发生的事情。阿西莫夫叙事的抛物线直接遵循了吉本的轨迹。所以你有帝国全权代表最后一次访问帝国前哨的场景。你得到了某种星际版的蛮族王国。好的，是的。
Sprouting up on, you know on planets that the empire has abandoned. You have a chapter in which the empire, a bit like Justinian, re-invading Italy, tries to reconstitute the empire. But the foundation itself, which gives its name to the series of novels, is something that has been founded. It's a foundation by a psycho historian, a guy called Harry Seldon. And he's a mathematician who has applied his kind of crunching of data to the past and has drawn up rules of history. So by looking to the past, he's been able to work out the future. And so he can tell that the empire is going to collapse. And he kind of plants the foundation to serve as a beacon of light amid the gathering darkness that he knows is going to come. So it's as though he has read his gibbon
在帝国遗弃的行星上涌现。你有一章写到帝国，有点像查士丁尼重新入侵意大利，试图重建帝国。但《基地》本身，也就是给系列小说命名的地方，是一个被建立的东西。这是一个由心理史学家哈里·谢顿建立的基地。他是一位数学家，将他那种数据处理能力应用到了过去，并制定了历史规则。所以通过审视过去，他能够推算出未来。所以他能看出帝国将会崩溃。他建立基地是为了在即将到来的黑暗中充当一盏明灯。所以就好像他读过吉本一样
and he thinks this is going to happen again, effectively. Yes, pretty much. And so the whole series of novels revolves around the fact that there are kind of what are called seldom events, where some catastrophic thing that most people couldn't have seen, but because he can, he's a psycho historian, he's been able to work it out. He knows what's going to happen. And actually, I think this is a trend that's particularly popular in American universities. There are historians who are very into the idea that you can kind of draw immutable lessons. So I guess the Thucydides trap would be the classic example. American sort of
他认为这会再次发生，实际上。是的，差不多。所以整个系列小说都围绕着所谓的“谢顿事件”，即一些大多数人无法预见、但因为他是心理史学家所以能够推算出来的灾难性事件。他知道会发生什么。实际上，我认为这是一种在美国大学里特别流行的趋势。有些历史学家非常热衷于那种你可以得出不可变教训的观点。所以我想修昔底德陷阱就是一个典型的例子。美国那种
military historians love to talk about that, don't they? Policymakers. Yeah. So this is the idea that a settled power will become the rival of a rising power. So Sparta goes to war with Athens. Britain goes to war with Germany. It's much applied now with regard to America and China. And really, this is an idea, this idea that you can have applied history is something that has been very popular in the United States throughout the 20th century. And Asimov is clearly drawing on that idea, I think, with the foundation. You know who would be a good, who's Harry Seldon, Tom? And Neil Ferguson. Neil Ferguson's all over this kind of thing. So Neil Ferguson did actually organise a conference on this very idea in Stanford,
军事历史学家喜欢谈论这个，不是吗？决策者。是的。所以这就是所谓的“应用历史学”观点，即一个既定的强权将成为新兴强权的对手。所以斯巴达与雅典开战。英国与德国开战。现在在美中关系中应用得很多。实际上，这种可以应用历史的观点在整个20世纪的美国非常流行。我认为阿西莫夫显然在《基地》中借鉴了那个观点。你知道谁会是一个好人选吗，谁是哈里·谢顿，汤姆？尼尔·弗格森。尼尔·弗格森到处都在谈论这种事情。所以尼尔·弗格森确实在斯坦福大学组织了一场关于这个想法的会议，
to which I was invited. Tom! Oh my word. One of 19 men and one woman. There was much uproar about this. I believe it was called a sausage fest. How did that woman get in? Unbelievable scenes. But you know, it was in California. I think the beast from the East was sweeping in over Britain. I went and enjoyed the sun. What predictions for the future did you offer?
我被邀请参加了。汤姆！天哪。19个男人和1个女人。对此引起了轩然大波。我相信它被称为“香肠派对”。那个女人是怎么进去的？难以置信的场面。但你知道，那是在加州。我想来自东方的野兽正席卷英国。我去了，享受了阳光。你对未来提出了什么预测？
I did something on undead Rome. I did it on looking at how ideas of Rome motivated Vladimir Putin. We ended up talking about it in one of the episodes. Never let anything go to waste. Anyway, this is still quite a current idea. But in the context of this idea that Gibbon articulates, that the fall of the Roman Empire is the greatest, perhaps the most awful scene in the history of mankind, he famously says, there is a great twist in the second novel, which is that Harry Seldon's reading of history turns out to go wrong. An event happens that he couldn't have foreseen. And this is the emergence of a character called the Mule, who is a mutant telepath. So he can read and manipulate the emotions of other people. And he ends up conquering
我做了一个关于“不死罗马”的演讲。我研究了罗马的观念是如何激励弗拉基米尔·普京的。我们在其中一集里谈到了它。永远不要浪费任何东西。总之，这仍然是一个非常当下的观点。但在吉本阐述的“罗马帝国的衰亡是人类历史上最伟大、也许是最可怕的场景”这一背景下，他有一句名言，第二部小说中有一个巨大的转折，那就是哈里·谢顿对历史的解读结果出错了。发生了一件他无法预见的事情。这就是一个叫“骡”的角色的出现，他是一个变异的通灵者。所以他可以读取和操纵他人的情绪。他最终征服了
the galaxy and conquering the foundation. He has not been predicted. I think that this is pretty clearly an echo of Muhammad. It's a fairly hostile portrayal of Muhammad. The mule is an arrogant conqueror. But I think it is an interesting twist because essentially what Asimov is saying there is that the emergence of Islam is a kind of, you know, a lightning bolt from the blue. It couldn't have been anticipated or foreseen. It's something so startling and unexpected that even the most highly advanced psycho historians could not have anticipated it. And that of course is buying into the traditional Islamic narrative
银河系并征服了基地。他没有被预测到。我认为这很明显是穆罕默德的回声。这是一个对穆罕默德相当敌意的描绘。骡是一个傲慢的征服者。但我认为这是一个有趣的转折，因为阿西莫夫本质上是在说，伊斯兰教的出现就像一道晴天霹雳。它是不可能被预料或预见的。它是如此令人震惊和出乎意料，以至于即使是最先进的心理史学家也无法预料到它。这当然是采纳了传统的伊斯兰叙事，
that Islam emerges because it is a revelation of God rather than emerging, as I think it probably did, in quite a predictable way from the melange of opinions and religious beliefs. If Harry Seldon, as a psycho, what is he, a psycho historian? Yeah. If he'd been trained in the 1970s and 1980s by a Patricia Croner figure, Tom. Yeah, he might have seen it. He would have seen it coming because he would have said Islam emerged out of
即伊斯兰教的出现是因为它是上帝的启示，而不是像我认为的那样，从各种观点和宗教信仰的混合中以一种相当可预测的方式出现。如果哈里·谢顿，作为一个心理学家，他是什么，心理史学家？是的。如果他在70年代和80年代受过帕特里夏·克罗内式人物的训练，汤姆。是的，他可能已经看到了。他会预见到它的到来，因为他会说伊斯兰教是从
the superpower conflicts in Arabia between the Romans and the Persians and stuff. But I guess what Asimov is reflecting is the orthodox historiography about the rise of Islam
阿拉伯半岛罗马人和波斯人之间的超级大国冲突中产生的。但我猜阿西莫夫反映的是关于伊斯兰教兴起的正统史学，
and the sort of 7th century at the time he was writing in the 1950s, right? As is another equally celebrated work of science fiction, a series of novels like Foundation that again have inspired not TV in this case, but a couple of films so far that are out on release. And that's Dune.
以及他写作时所在的20世纪50年代的7世纪，对吧？还有另一部同样著名的科幻作品，像《基地》一样的系列小说，这次激发的不是电视剧，而是目前已经上映的两部电影。那就是《沙丘》。
Right. And Dune was written in the 60s by a guy called Frank Herbert. And it's set on an inhospitable desert, a bit like, what is it? Tatooine, is it? In Star Wars. Or Jakku. So this is Arrakis yeah it's um full of giant kind of sandworms and things but what arrakis produces is a kind of weird thing
对。而《沙丘》是60年代由一个叫弗兰克·赫伯特的人写的。它设定在一个荒凉的沙漠上，有点像，是什么来着？塔图因，是吗？在《星球大战》里。或者贾库。所以这就是厄拉科斯，是的，它充满了巨大的沙虫之类的东西，但厄拉科斯产生了一种奇怪的东西
called spice yes that effectively powers space travel which is also called melange rather oddly or melange yes so it's i mean this is this is um just before opec so it's, I mean, this is, this is, um, just before OPEC. So it's pretty clear that this is spice in a way is oil, but I think it is clearly also an echo of, um, the idea that was very, very current, uh, when Herbert was writing this and, and which Patricia Kroner delivered a kind of devastating rebuttal to the idea that Mecca had been a great centre of the spice trade and that this is the context from which Muhammad emerges, that Mecca was this hugely significant centre. I think it's absolutely clear that it wasn't at all. And that this sense of Mecca as a centre of spice trade is a kind of Orientalist fantasy that's projected onto the understanding
叫香料，是的，它有效地驱动了太空旅行，也被奇怪地称为“美琅脂”或“美琅脂”，是的。所以我的意思是，这就在欧佩克之前，所以很明显，香料在某种程度上就是石油，但我认为它显然也是一种回声，即赫伯特写这本书时非常非常流行的观点，而帕特里夏·克罗内对此进行了毁灭性的反驳，即麦加曾是香料贸易的伟大中心，而这就是穆罕默德出现的背景，即麦加是一个极其重要的中心。我认为很明显它根本不是。而这种将麦加视为香料贸易中心的观念，是一种东方主义幻想，被投射到西方学者对
of Islam by Western scholars who have this idea that anything Orientalist fantasy that's projected onto the understanding of Islam by Western scholars who have this idea that anything Oriental must have to do with spice. And then it's turbocharged by the oil crisis. Why does it matter in the history of Islam and the sort of collapse of the Roman authority in the Eastern Mediterranean? Why does it matter whether Mecca had spices or not? I don't think it does particularly matter. I mean, it matters very much to explaining the traditional accounts of Islam as history, because in the traditional accounts, Mecca is clearly a very significant settlement
伊斯兰教的理解上，他们认为任何东方主义幻想都必须与香料有关。然后它被石油危机涡轮增压了。为什么麦加是否有香料在伊斯兰历史和罗马权威在东地中海的崩溃中很重要？我不认为这特别重要。我的意思是，这对于解释作为历史的传统伊斯兰叙事非常重要，因为在传统叙事中，麦加显然是一个非常重要的定居点，
with all kinds of competing aristocracies. And historically, that doesn't seem to be the case. There is no record of a Mecca that would correspond to a centre that rich and that significant in any of the contemporary sources. But that idea of competing clans and aristocracies fighting for control of the spice trade, let's say, I mean, that is the plot of Dune, isn't it? Yes.
有着各种相互竞争的贵族。而从历史上看，情况似乎并非如此。在任何当代文献中，都没有关于麦加对应于如此富有和重要的中心的记录。但那种相互竞争的氏族和贵族为争夺香料贸易控制权而斗争的观念，这就是《沙丘》的情节，不是吗？是的。
The Harkonnens and the House Atreus, isn't it? Yeah. The Greek name. Yeah, it is. So the House of Atreus, that's the family of Agamemnon. Yeah. And Paul Atreides, so Paul, the son of Atreus, that's the family of Agamemnon. And Paul Atreides, so Paul, the son of Atreus, actually the parallels are not really with Greek myth. It's again, it's with Islamic
哈克南家族和阿特雷迪斯家族，不是吗？是的。希腊名字。是的，确实。所以阿特雷迪斯家族，那是阿伽门农的家族。是的。保罗·阿特雷迪斯，所以保罗，阿特雷乌斯的儿子，实际上这些相似之处并不是真的与希腊神话有关。这又是与伊斯兰
history, I think, because Paul goes on to become Muad'Dib, which in Arabic means teacher, although in Dune, it actually means kangaroo mouse. So it's one of the animals of the desert. And he goes on to kind of become a prophetic figure, a long run for the Roman Empire and suggests that, you know, for these deeply totemic science fiction stories, it's the fall of the Roman Empire rather than the fall of the Roman Republic that is the kind of the great inspiration. Just one thing on Paul. Paul is also, so we talked about Luke Skywalker is King Arthur. Paul is also King Arthur as well, isn't he? He is. He has this sort of providential destiny that he is sort of fated. People talk about him in hushed tones.
历史有关，我想，因为保罗后来成为了穆阿迪布，在阿拉伯语中意为“老师”，尽管在《沙丘》中，它实际上意味着“袋鼠鼠”。所以它是沙漠中的动物之一。他后来成为了一种预言性的人物，对罗马帝国来说是一场漫长的奔跑，并暗示，你知道，对于这些深刻的图腾式科幻故事来说，是罗马帝国的衰亡而不是罗马共和国的衰亡才是伟大的灵感来源。关于保罗的一件事。保罗也是，所以我们谈到卢克·天行者是亚瑟王。保罗也是亚瑟王，不是吗？他是。他有一种天命，他注定如此。人们低声谈论他。
Is he going to be the person who fulfills the prophecy and all that kind of stuff? Yeah, and I think that that's so interesting. I mean, you're absolutely right. There are echoes of Arthur as well as of Muhammad. And both of them, so the stories of Arthur are starting to emerge and be written down at around the same time as the biographies of Muhammad. The first biographies of Muhammad are starting to be written kind of around 800 AD. And both of them are kind of responses to the collapse of the Roman empire. They're both about the emergence
他会是那个实现预言的人吗，诸如此类的事情？是的，我认为这太有趣了。我的意思是，你是绝对正确的。既有亚瑟的回声，也有穆罕默德的回声。他们两个，亚瑟的故事开始出现并被记录下来，大约与穆罕默德的传记在同一时间。穆罕默德的第一批传记开始在公元800年左右被撰写。他们两个都是对罗马帝国崩溃的回应。他们都是关于
of charismatic figures on the margins of the empire who take control of abandoned imperial territory. And so that's why I think it's possible to see, say in Dune, echoes both of Arthur and of Muhammad in this story, because the original stories are both generated by this kind of catastrophic event, if you're Roman. And I think it's clear why science fiction offers scope for people who want to explore the kind of the great dramas of ancient history but don't want to write historical fiction because if you have an enormous galactic empire you know you can make play with that yeah in a way that you can't just you know down on earth yes so battle star galactica would be another example of that i guess oh yeah of course battle star galactica which is kind of
帝国边缘的魅力型人物的出现，他们控制了被遗弃的帝国领土。所以我认为这就是为什么在《沙丘》中看到亚瑟和穆罕默德的回声是可能的，因为原始故事都是由这种灾难性事件产生的，如果你是罗马人的话。而且我认为很清楚为什么科幻小说为那些想探索古代历史伟大戏剧但又不想写历史小说的人提供了空间，因为如果你有一个巨大的银河帝国，你知道，你可以利用它，是的，以一种你在地球上无法做到的方式。是的，所以《太空堡垒卡拉狄加》是另一个例子，我想。哦，是的，当然，《太空堡垒卡拉狄加》，它有点像
mormonism i can't yeah there is this idea that it's inspired by the age of the mormons anyway so so tom do you have anything else up your sleeve i suspect you do i know you do well you know i do so there's one other way in which the roman empire has served as an inspiration for science fiction and that is a particular and distinctive aspect of its culture which we have already alluded to when we discussed gladiator which in so many ways could be thought of as a science fiction film i think you know you think of the napalm that is fired in the the opening battle the vast overweening scale with which rome is portrayed there's a sense in which the examples of science fiction are being woven back into history yeah or fantasy, I suppose. Or fantasy, yes. But gladiatorial combat has featured in a
摩门教，我不能，是的，有一种观点认为它受到摩门教时代的启发。总之，汤姆，你还有什么锦囊妙计吗？我怀疑你有，我知道你有。好吧，你知道我有。所以罗马帝国作为科幻小说灵感的另一种方式是其文化中一个独特且显著的方面，我们在讨论《角斗士》时已经提到过，它在许多方面可以被认为是一部科幻电影。我想，你知道，你想到在开场战斗中发射的凝固汽油弹，罗马被描绘的那种巨大的、傲慢的规模，在某种意义上，科幻小说的例子正被编织回历史中。是的，或者幻想，我想。或者幻想，是的。但角斗士格斗在
number of science fiction stories. And if Star Wars is one of the great science fiction franchises that emerged from the 60s and 70s, the other one, of course, is Star Trek. And you do get a Roman empire. They're called the Romulans. So name is obviously comes from romulus yes so they're introduced in in the first series in 1966 but in the second series which came out in 1968 you have an episode called bread and circuses so the famous phrase from juvenile which describes what the how the emperors kept the people of rome happy and in that kirk spock and mccoy so the three main figures in the in the first series get captured by a civilization that is basically rome but in the mid-20th century and spock and mccoy get made to fight as gladiators and this is the um the roman
许多科幻故事中都有出现。如果《星球大战》是60和70年代出现的伟大科幻系列之一，另一个当然是《星际迷航》。你确实得到了一个罗马帝国。他们被称为罗慕伦人。所以名字显然来自罗慕路斯，是的，所以他们在1966年的第一季中被引入，但在1968年播出的第二季中，你有一集叫《面包与马戏》，这是尤维纳利斯的名言，描述了皇帝们如何让罗马人民保持快乐。在剧中，柯克、斯波克和麦考伊——第一季中的三个主要人物——被一个基本上是罗马但处于20世纪中叶的文明俘虏了，斯波克和麦考伊被迫作为角斗士战斗。这是
officials who are announcing they say it'll be shown on television in colour. So there you go. That really dates it. It does. Yeah, it does. And again, a bit like in Star Wars, you have these kind of shadowy figures. They're worshippers of the sun. And at the end, they all survive. They get beamed back up. And Mr. Spock is kind of musing how extraordinary the parallels between ancient Rome and Rome on this planet are. But then he says, but I do not remember there being
宣布这一消息的罗马官员，他们说它将在电视上以彩色播出。所以你看。这真的让它过时了。确实。是的，确实。而且，有点像在《星球大战》中，你有这些阴影人物。他们是太阳崇拜者。最后，他们都幸存了下来。他们被传送回去了。斯波克先生在沉思古代罗马和这个星球上的罗马之间的相似之处是多么非凡。但随后他说，但我并不记得有
worshippers of the sun in Rome. Well, that's wrong. There were, weren't there? I mean, Sol Invictus. Yeah, of course, of course. But at this point, Lieutenant Uhura pipes up and says that she has been monitoring broadcasts from the planet and reveals they're not worshipping the sun, S-U-N, but the sun, S-O-N.
太阳崇拜者在罗马。好吧，那是错的。有，不是吗？我的意思是，无敌太阳神。是的，当然，当然。但在这一点上，乌胡拉中尉插话说，她一直在监测来自该星球的广播，并透露他们崇拜的不是太阳（SUN），而是圣子（SON）。
Oh, my word, Tom. Really? And Captain Kirk, Caesar and Christ, they have them both. And the word is spreading only now. Crikey. So that is very sword and sandals biblical epic. That's the ultimate embodiment of kind of Cold War America, isn't it? Yeah, it is.
天哪，汤姆。真的吗？柯克船长，“凯撒与基督”，他们两者兼有。而且这个词直到现在才传播开来。天哪。所以那是非常“剑与凉鞋”的圣经史诗。那是冷战美国的一种终极体现，不是吗？是的，它是。
Incredible. I mean, obviously it's a pun that doesn't work in Latin. No. But, I mean, I think you can see why the idea of gladiators, the idea of people being made to fight for the entertainment of viewers is something that works really, really well in an era with television. And if you project that into the future, then you have scope for a whole range of kind of plots. So there's the Arnie one, isn't there? The Running Man. But I think the most celebrated recent franchise where the
难以置信。我的意思是，显然这是一个在拉丁语中行不通的双关语。不。但是，我的意思是，我认为你可以看出为什么角斗士的想法，即人们被迫为观众的娱乐而战的想法，在电视时代是非常非常有效的。如果你把它投射到未来，那么你就有了一系列情节的空间。所以有阿诺的那一部，不是吗？《过关斩将》。但我认为最近最著名的系列，其中
echoes of Roma are really, really overt. It's not set in space, but it is set in the future. And that's The Hunger Games. So it's set in North America where the United States has imploded and there are kind of all these various outlying districts who have to send a tribute of boys and girls where they are then made to fight the Hunger Games. They basically kind of, you know, they will have to kill each other. So it's about Theseus. Yeah. So that is obviously drawing on the Theseus myth, but the setting is Roman. So the idea of gladiatorial combat, the capital is called Capitol. All right. As in the capital in Rome.
罗马的回声非常非常明显。它不是设定在太空中，但它设定在未来。那就是《饥饿游戏》。所以它设定在北美，美国已经崩溃，有各种各样的偏远地区，他们必须派遣男孩和女孩作为贡品，然后被迫参加饥饿游戏。他们基本上，你知道，他们必须互相残杀。所以它是关于忒修斯的。是的。所以这显然借鉴了忒修斯神话，但背景是罗马式的。所以角斗士格斗的想法，首都被称为“凯匹特”（Capitol）。好的。就像罗马的国会大厦。
And the country itself is called Panem. So bread, as in the bread and circuses of the Star Trek episode we were just talking about. And the president is Coriolanus Snow. Coriolanus Snow. So Snow, that's not Roman, but Coriolanus Snow. Coriolanus Snow. So Snow, that's not Roman, but Coriolanus is. And pretty much all the characters in it, apart from the heroine, have kind of classical names. There's kind of Plutarch, Cato,
国家本身被称为“施惠国”（Panem）。所以是面包，就像我们刚才谈到的《星际迷航》那一集里的“面包与马戏”。总统是科里奥兰纳斯·斯诺。科里奥兰纳斯·斯诺。所以斯诺，那不是罗马式的，但科里奥兰纳斯是。而且除了女主角之外，里面的几乎所有角色都有某种古典名字。有普鲁塔克、加图，
all kinds of people like that. And I think that Hunger Games is a really good example of the way in which a sprinkling of the Roman in a science fiction film, in a futuristic film, gives it a little bit of class.
各种各样的人。而且我认为《饥饿游戏》是一个很好的例子，说明了在科幻电影、未来主义电影中加入一点罗马元素，会给它带来一点档次。
Yeah, it does. I like that, Tom. I've never seen The Hunger Games. You've seen it about 30 times, haven't you? Yeah, I have because my daughters loved it. Is it good?
是的，确实。我喜欢那个，汤姆。我从来没看过《饥饿游戏》。你已经看过大约30次了，不是吗？是的，我看过，因为我的女儿们很喜欢它。它好吗？
Yeah, it's great. Really? Crikey. And it has Woody Harrelson who I saw on the London stage a couple of weeks ago. What was he doing? He was in a brilliant play
是的，很棒。真的吗？天哪。而且它有伍迪·哈里森，我几周前在伦敦舞台上见过他。他在做什么？他在一部精彩的戏剧里
called, I think, American Ulster or Ulster American. I can't remember which way round it was. Tom, you saw it too? Andy Serkis. You saw it two weeks ago and you don't remember what it was called? Was it Ulster American or American Ulster american i can't remember which way around it was something you saw it too andy circus you saw it two weeks ago you don't remember what it was called well it's ulster american or
叫，我想，是《美国阿尔斯特》还是《阿尔斯特美国》。我不记得是哪种顺序了。汤姆，你也看了？安迪·瑟金斯。你两周前看了，却不记得它叫什么？是《阿尔斯特美国》还是《美国阿尔斯特》？我记不清是哪种顺序了，某样东西，你也看了，安迪·瑟金斯，你两周前看了，却不记得它叫什么？好吧，是《阿尔斯特美国》还是
american ulster i can't remember okay and a girl from an actress from dairy girls okay it's really really funny i highly recommend it crikey this this conversation is unexpected i know we didn't think we'd end up end up with that talking about dairy girls so last question what is it why rome why not greece why not i mean obviously i guess not persia not another empire because it's rome So last question, what is it? Why Rome? Why not Greece? Why not? I mean, obviously, I guess not Persia, not another empire, because it's Rome that is at the center that sort of underlies the Western imagination. Is that the argument? It's glamorous. It's got great visuals.
《美国阿尔斯特》，我记不清了。好吧，还有一个来自《德里女孩》的女演员。好的，它真的真的很有趣，我强烈推荐它。天哪，这次谈话太出乎意料了。我知道，我们没想到最后会谈到《德里女孩》。所以最后一个问题，为什么是罗马？为什么不是希腊？为什么不是？我的意思是，显然，我猜不是波斯，不是另一个帝国，因为是罗马，它是处于西方想象力核心的那个，是它构成了基础。这是论点吗？它很迷人。它有很棒的视觉效果。
It can stand in for sinister empires, whether it's the British Empire or the Nazis or the Soviet Union or whatever. But it has a kind of iconography that's immediately recognisable. It has customs that we find unsettling, but exciting. Well, violence, basically. So violence, so slavery and gladiatorial combat and whips and all kinds of things that when you look at those films in the 50s yeah there's a clear kind of sadomasochistic there's a hell of a lot of whipping in those films there's a lot of whipping in it yeah and um it's also quite classy i think yeah i mean you know the study of latin has been a kind of marker of class right from the beginning of the american republic so and i suppose you could argue that in our kind of political imagination those two events the evolution of the republic into an empire and
它可以代表邪恶的帝国，无论是大英帝国、纳粹还是苏联等等。但它有一种一眼就能认出来的肖像学。它有一些我们觉得不安但又令人兴奋的习俗。好吧，暴力，基本上。所以暴力，所以奴隶制和角斗士格斗，鞭子，以及各种各样的事情，当你回顾50年代的那些电影时，是的，有一种明显的施虐受虐倾向，那些电影里有很多鞭打，有很多鞭打，是的，而且它也相当有档次，我想。是的，我的意思是，你知道，拉丁语的学习从美利坚共和国建立之初就是一种阶级的标志。所以我猜你可以说，在我们那种政治想象中，那两个事件——共和国演变为帝国，
then the decline and fall of the empire that those are kind of foundational aren't they yeah absolutely you know that all almost all political creeds have them have some sense of them at their heart somewhere anyway yeah i mean as you know to repeat gibbon it it is the greatest and most awful scene. And maybe you need the galaxy to truly do it justice. Yes, you do, Tom. We certainly began this podcast with the greatest and most awful impression. Actually, do you know what? It was a pretty good Dave Prowse. I thought it was. It's very similar to the impression that you did, for our American listeners will enjoy this, of John Adams, the founding father of the United States. Because that, of course, is how early Americans
然后帝国的衰亡——它们是某种基础，不是吗？是的，绝对。你知道，几乎所有的政治信条都在它们的核心某处有某种对它们的感知。总之，是的，我的意思是，正如你所知，重复吉本的话，它是最伟大、最可怕的场景。也许你需要整个银河系才能真正公正地对待它。是的，你需要，汤姆。我们当然是以最伟大、最可怕的印象开始了这期播客。实际上，你知道吗？那是一个相当不错的戴夫·普劳斯模仿。我觉得是。它和你做的模仿非常相似——我们的美国听众会喜欢这个——约翰·亚当斯，美利坚合众国的国父。因为那当然是早期美国人
spoke. Right, on that bombshell, Tom, I actually enjoyed this episode far more than is healthy. And that's a terrible thing to say about your own episodes, because it makes us look very self-indulgent. Yeah, but we needed it after all the Nazis, didn't we? A palate cleanser. And people being locked
说话的方式。好吧，带着这个重磅炸弹，汤姆，我实际上享受这一集远超过了健康的程度。对于你自己的节目来说，这是一个可怕的说法，因为它让我们看起来非常自我放纵。是的，但在经历了所有的纳粹之后，我们需要它，不是吗？一种味觉清洁剂。还有被锁在
up in iron masks. Exactly. So we'll be back, I believe, Tom, with the reign of King Richard II. We will. And the Peasants' Revolt. And the Peasants' Revolt. And all kinds of exciting goings-on in medieval England. So we will see you next week.
铁面具里的人。正是如此。所以我想我们会回来的，汤姆，带着理查德二世国王的统治。我们会回来的。还有农民起义。还有农民起义。以及中世纪英格兰各种令人兴奋的事情。所以我们下周见。
Bye-bye. Bye-bye. I'm Marina Hyde and I'm Richard Osman and together we host The Rest Is Entertainment it's your weekly fix of entertainment news reviews
再见。再见。我是玛丽娜·海德，我是理查德·奥斯曼，我们共同主持《剩下的就是娱乐》，这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论、
splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works we have just launched our members club if you want ad free listening
一点演艺圈八卦的固定节目，在我们的问答环节，我们将揭开娱乐界的幕布，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部，如果你想要无广告收听、
bonus episodes and early access to live tickets head to therestisentertainment.com There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
额外剧集以及提前获得现场演出门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。